ouverture aujourd'hui du smart cities
expo montréal une conférence
internationale qui réunit les
administrations publiques les experts
internationaux et les entreprises
spécialisées en développement urbain qui
planche sur un concept qu'on va entendre
de plus en plus souvent la ville
intelligente match est galement soir
alors la ville intelligente de quoi
parle-t-on exactement leur manière de
voir cette chose là est un fourre-tout
le verre à moitié vide c'est de se dire
que c'est un beau slogan pour des
administrations qui sont toujours en mal
de beau slogan le verre à moitié plein
maintenant c'est que c'est une manière
de tirer parti de la technologie pour
rendre la ville plus efficace pour
l'administration et pour les citoyens
donc ces bases est vraiment sur le
numérique sur la mobilité est absolument
comme par exemple si on se place du côté
de la ville la ville peut dire écoutez
nous on a des grands ensembles de
données on va les rendre publics pour
que des petites compagnies puissent
aller piger là dedans puis faire des
applications qui sont efficaces par
exemple l'horaire des piscines
on pourrait penser qu'on rend son public
et qu'elle est il ya des gens qui font
développer ça pète on reprend se
géolocaliser pour aller voir si on peut
aller se baigner avec la famille d'après
midi du côté des citoyens mais c'est
qu'on tire parti des données qui sont
générés par les citoyens pour connaître
l'état de la ville en temps réel
imaginez une ville bardés de capteurs
comme par exemple la circulation ont pu
connaître la circulation en temps réel
en voyant en géolocalisant les gens qui
sont dans leur automobile donc c'est
vraiment un jeu entre le citoyen et
l'administration au niveau des
applications justement ça se traduit
comment ben il faut que l'administration
publique sache laisser les entreprises à
faire des choses efficace comme par
exemple un exemple c'est l'application
transit qui était développé par une
compagnie montréalaise qui permet de
géolocaliser pour savoir où sont les
horaires de transports en commun le
meilleur transport en commun autour de
nous mais cette application leur a été
adopté dans 91 région métropolitaine
dans le monde des très bien cotés sur l'
app store a contrario de l'application
d'un stm qui elle est vraiment décrié
alors des fois c'est bon de laisser la
place au privé pour faire des bonnes
applications
oui on peut penser aussi le
stationnement et oui oui airbnb du
stationnement ça fait partie de la ville
intelligente
mais quand même l'administration la
ville peut créer des conditions
favorables pour développer justement ce
concept est oui et ça c'est le pari par
exemple du bureau de la ville
intelligente à montréal qui a annoncé un
plan triennal au mois de janvier dernier
ses 23 millions sur évidemment trois ans
on veut miser sur les technologies de
l'information pour améliorer les
déplacements soient ceux comme on vient
de parler offrir davantage de services
en ligne et rendre aussi la gestion de
la ville plus transparents avaient
l'intelligence et aussi de la démocratie
mais ça coûte cher en à tout ça peut
coûter cher on sait qu'à québec et des
lobbyistes qui sont présents pour vendre
des solutions informatiques en une
trentaine de yb ibm et microsoft alors
c'est un marché énorme des dizaines de
milliards de dollars par année
alors il faudrait quand on parle de
villes intelligentes avoir
l'intelligence au moins d'être critique
face à ce concept qui peut être vraiment
très pratique mais qui pourraient aussi
si on y regarde de plus près nous coûter
très cher donc l'intelligence face à la
ville intelligente